when the beastly scourge crept into
yharnam the people responded with the
hunt with iron and fire the populace
rallied to purify this city they fought
alongside the hunters who were talented
warriors properly equipped to counter
the beasts together you would have
thought that they'd stand a chance yet
when we arrived in yharnam something
seems wrong the hunt continues
but the populace has changed the line
between man and beast is blurred and
perhaps it was the bloodlust that the
hunt inspired that further awakened that
beast within man the hunters become
hated and feared for they turned into
the most terrible beasts to prevent this
from happening there has always been a
hunter of hunters a hunter with the
resolve to hunt former comrades who
succumbed to their thirst for blood
hunters of hunters dress as crows to
suggest sky burial I quote they hunt
with the hope that former compatriots
might be returned to the skies and find
rest in a hunter's dream Eileen is one
of these hunters and she was likely
recruited when the hunters workshop was
still in its infancy she wields the
blades of mercy forged with siderite
which is a rare mineral of the heavens
this weapon and Herman's burial blade
are the only weapons of their kind
they're masterpieces that defined the
entire array of weapons crafted at the
workshop eventually the hunters workshop
was no longer needed
but gurmann went on to become a host of
the hunters dream and started to guide
hunters into the waking world like us
and many other hunters Eileen visited
the dream too when a hunter of the dream
dies in the waking world their
consciousness retreats to the hunter's
dream from here it seems that they can
set out and brave that night again with
the dream to sustain her
Eileen must have been a force to be
reckoned with everyone needs something
that they
that a skill a talent eileen skill was
that she had the control to resist the
intoxicating effects of the hunt and the
ability to deal with hunters who were
too far gone when a hunter gave in to
bloodlust Eileen would swoop in and kill
him or her before they could do any more
damage her very unique hunts protected
the other hunters from themselves and
she did this task until her age caught
up with her and even beyond that because
the Eileen we meet is very old indeed
but one day she stopped dreaming over
time
countless hunters have visited his dream
the graves here stand in their memory it
all seems so long ago now farewell good
hunter may you find your worth in the
waking world no more dreams for me this
is my last chance so like many other
hunters before her Eileen was freed from
the dream German hosts of the hunters
dream granted her mercy but did she go
willingly
or did she simply outlive her usefulness
whatever the case we might never know
Mylene remains in yharnam and continues
her hunt her purpose unfulfilled Oh a
hunter are you and an outsider what a
mess you've been caught up in and
tonight of all nights prepare yourself
for the worst there are no humans left
there are flesh hungry beasts now
without the dream Eileen's death is
permanent yet still she remains in
yharnam proud undeterred and determined
to hunt down every last hunter who poses
the threat but eileen is one of the
oldest characters we encounter and
without your help she will perish in any
assassination she attempts that wasn't
necessary of you but you have my thanks
we made it with our lives
you're not bad at all you must have kill
gasps gone as well then he was falling
apart I'm sure it had to be done but try
to keep your hands clean a hunter should
hunt beasts leave the hunting of hunters
to me her pride is untouched and she
continues to place herself in harm's way
Oh is that you again I'm afraid I've
made a bit of a blunder
I'm just going to have a short rest
though don't worry I have taken blood
enough to save an old woman but that
thing still lies in wait turn back this
is my score to settle
Eileen's trail of assassinations
eventually leads her to the most
powerful hunter in the waking world
people call him the bloody crow of
cainhurst but to Eileen he is likely a
former comrade and possibly one of
Germany's first apprentices let's note
three things about him one he wears the
crow feather set as Eileen does
suggesting that he is or was a hunter of
hunters two he has mastered the art of
quickening and - is about with extreme
speed and this art is particular to the
first hunters of the workshop indeed we
tease this art from a hunter's remains
once this hunter was likely an
apprentice to German one of the first
thirdly the bloody crow uses the weapons
and armor of cainhurst which is a
faraway land ruled by a queen who craves
the blood of hunters he drops the blood
rapture wound which resonates with
servants of the Queen whoever he is he
seems to no longer see a purpose in
hunting beasts he and Eileen are not so
different in that respect
in fact Eileen could just as easily find
herself in his place
if you don't aid her on her journey and
she does
she becomes almost like the townsfolk of
yharnam who see nothing but evil when
they look at another hunter the Beast
cannot be stopped
what good hunters now your bloat is
mafia monsters all hunters must die but
you do a die lean and she doesn't lose
herself she lies here on the steps
bloodied and broken after her fight to
pass along her duty to another hunter
don't you ever listen to your elders no
matter you did save my life
I don't seem to be apt for this life
anymore my glory days were long a girl
now I know yeah for you
these two is hunters work but it bears
no honor their burden you may choose to
carry the decision is yours alone oh my
eyes grow heavy let me rest a while ah
after all this you should be questioning
the hunt many characters do its purpose
is of course to hunt beasts but it was
the hunt itself that further awakened
the beast hood within man its unleashed
the blood crazed hunters upon the world
men and women who individually can do
more damage than any mere animal and
when all is said and done when you have
painted yharnam with the blood of its
men and women who turned into beasts who
did you really kill for is it really
mercy that gurmann shows to those who
exit the dream or are we removed because
we came too close to the truth after all
once you wake it's difficult to remember
what you dreamed about
you